you ready
we'll get started first question kelly
eco
hey russ uh overall how would you assess
how you guys operated against their zone
tonight
uh not bad we made some adjustments
and found ways to be able to get into
paint find open shots
hey russ uh when they're trapping james
the way they're doing on the wings
do you prefer to be um in the middle of
the paint or
like tonight it seemed like that you
were just in the perimeter more so like
in the right
early in the season where you were
attacking off the catch
yeah i don't know i just right now i'm
just running around
so i gotta look at film and figure out
how to be effective
tim mcmahon
russ what do you think uh was the cause
of of your turnovers tonight
um some something's my fault someone
missed calls um
but you know it's on me i don't point
fingers and nobody else
in my own game on my mistakes on what i
do
um and that's it
if you have to pinpoint to one single
mistake you guys made
the cuts to the game what would you say
uh
that's not realistic uh
can can you then say what do you think
is the
mistakes you made that goes to the games
you guys have a team obviously
next question okay
we don't have any more brian smith
ross mike was just saying how great of a
player you are and
he knows you'll snap out of this
offensively
what do you do on the court to try to
what's that sorry it's not part of what
what do you what do you do offensively
during this series to try to try to get
yourself going
i'm confused you said snap out of snap
out of what
uh struggling to shoot the ball
and yes today yeah
oh man that happens it's okay
i'm gonna come back next time i'll be
ready to go it's only serious only it's
1-1
i played six games in this series
there's one more
thanks
kim davis
it was what can you say about how um the
game started with them
if you guys not having quite the
intensity that you usually have and how
do you guys correct that for the next
game
uh you gotta be ready to go from the
start you knew that was gonna come out
and be aggressive
um and we wasn't ready to go it took us
some time to
get warmed up to the game and we know we
can't afford to do that
thank you russell
let me know when you're ready ready
first question kelly eco
hey james overall as a team how would
you guys assess how you uh played the
zone
that they showed at times
uh they caught us off guard but i think
uh later in the game
we did a pretty good job of it um you
know we just didn't we weren't
aggressive enough
and we didn't attack their zone enough
um and you know they gave them
confidence they started making shots and
that's it do you have any other
questions
kelly eco sorry
i have one question um what do you think
the best way to attack that kind of zone
is it just
ball movement or it wasn't even i mean
it wasn't his own it just came out
and played you know harder than us i
felt like and
um finally in the second half we woke up
and you know we took the lead so we just
gotta you know have that intensity from
beginning the game will be all right
thank you tim mcmahon
james russ obviously is in a tough
situation coming off an injury
such a long uh laying off and you know
trying to get back to peak form during
the playoffs
what can he do to get himself back in a
rhythm how can you guys help him
russ would be fine he's great
you know uh and the great thing about
russ
he does more just to affect the game
other than the squad of basketball
you know he's so athletic he's so great
that he can affect it with his defense
he can
be a playmaker he does a variety of
things to impact the game of basketball
for our team so you know we're not
worried about it
mark berman
hey james it's often said that when you
get down big and you come back it takes
a lot out of you to get back to where
you want to be
how much that do you feel like that
affected the overall
where you guys are at how y'all played
fourth quarter it didn't it did
you know obviously michigan gave them a
24 point
advantage anyways but uh when we came
back we still had the energy we still
had the effort
we just couldn't make shots we missed i
turned the ball over a couple times we
had a couple turnovers
you know they make some shots and you
know let's hit that off so
dan wokey hey james um
you mentioned kind of their early game
energy and how they played harder
how much of that did you see from lebron
and a.d and those guys just being much
more aggressive than they were in game
one
old team
cody davis
hey james um you guys scored 41 points
in that third quarter so
is there anything you guys can take away
from that quarter that could help you
guys in game three
yeah we just we matched our intensity
you know they came all aggressive
and i mean i think we still did a pretty
good job only being down
a few points towards into the first
quarter but you know we gave them that
run
you know and which got them up to 20
some points and
um i guess any team no matter you know
what team it is in this league it's
tough to come back from
uh down you know 20 20 some points but
we did and we gave ourselves a chance so
you take away that and it's a you know a
pretty good game
last one julio alonza
hey james uh it seems a little bit that
the lakers are
using their small ball even though they
have anthem
davis has this created a little bit of
no problems offensively for you guys no
not at all nope it was our defense
thank you james